bismillah r-rahman r-rahim al-hamdu
lillahi rabbil alameen a solid wa sallam
ala rasulina Kareem while early he was
happy his main I my bad we're getting
started off here a few minutes later
than two I had a funeral that I had to
attend which I just returned from today
in shablow tada we are going to speak
about a very pertinent topic and it's a
topic that directly links to our topic
last week so our topic last week was
regarding a to file what we mentioned at
the Toyota is believing in bad omens
believing in bad luck and we mentioned
that this belief in bad luck it can be
regarding anything it could be in times
places certain actions certain
statements all of these things can be
part of bad luck so for example in
America at Ulta you in in in terms of
places would be where you know murders
take place or some kind of tragedy took
place we tend to often believe in
America that this place is now somehow
haunted because of this tragedy all
right or a suicide or a haunted house or
these things at the file regarding a
certain number the number 13 also
certain dates Friday the 13th which
actually goes back to Christianity
because it was believed that Judas the
one who allegedly betrayed Jesus in the
way that the New Testament places puts
it he betrayed Jesus
and he was the 13th person to arrive
during the Last Supper and that last
supper was on Friday alleging that the
crucifixion of the alleged crucifixion
of Jesus even took place on Friday which
it did not it could not have not if
we're going to make it three days and
Palm Sunday so anyways this is a type of
Tafoya so Friday the 13th is considered
an ominous foreboding time right also at
the thigh you'll with regards to certain
actions spilling salt certain
actions such as walking under a ladder
or certain actions regarding breaking a
mirror for example or certain things
that occur a black cat walking a
prop across a person's path etc etc all
of these things are bad omens they are
not bad omens in the sense that they are
considered to be by many people
superstitiously and uncorrect and
incorrectly they are considered to be
bad omens but we know as Muslims that
this has no bearing on reality these
things do not affect reality at all they
have no connection to us these things
are mere coincidence right so if you are
walking down the street and a black cat
crosses your path and then right after
that a person you know something that
happens there is there there is
correlation there right these things
happened at the same time but a very
important principle
and logic is that correlation does not
necessitate causation right just because
something happens at the same time as
something else doesn't mean that it is
the cause of it right so let's say for
example every morning I wake up and have
a slice of toast and at that same time
the news happens to come on and every
morning I watch the Morning News
if people even do that anymore every
morning I eat a slice of toast and watch
the Morning News that is correlation
these two things are happening
simultaneously they are happening at the
same time but this does not mean that
the morning news is caused by me eating
a slice of toast there there is no
connection with regards to cause they're
human beings we are we often because we
are hardwired we are predisposed to look
for patterns we are predisposed to look
for patterns and reason and so because
of this we often confuse correlation
with causation and there there is not
necessarily a connection there so these
alleged bad omens these things that
allegedly occur this is bad luck or that
is bad luck all of these things we
discussed last week now I want to note
something and that is there is a
difference between a total which is when
a person makes a connection between a
certain act or ritual or something and
bad luck which we described and
explained very in great detail last week
there is a difference between that and
between looking
towards the actions of a loss of Hannah
what data right so if I for example see
a number of things fall into place that
would facilitate a particular thing to
occur it is okay to assume that these
things may that these things may may be
an indication of something good or bad
that may be going to happen right so for
example if I am standing outside and the
wind picks up and the sky becomes very
dark and lightning and hail starts to
fall and then I make the assumption that
it is very likely that a tornado is
going to touch down that is fine that is
not to file because these are the causes
and these are the effects of that
particular thing which is a tornado a
loss of Panama to isla speaks about this
throughout the Quran and the scholars of
Islam have sum this up and said either
arad Allah who say and Kas Babel
if Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala desires or
wills that something occur
he will preface that occurrence with its
causes the things that will cause it
things that will facilitate that
particular thing to occur right that is
different than to failed because when I
am looking at the causes of a particular
thing if I am looking at something that
will facilitate a particular thing and
then predict that in the sense that I
believe that this may happen because I
see these particular causes then
that is different than a person looking
to something that has no connection to
that particular thing it is merely
coincidental correlation right the
black cat crossing your path has no no
bearing whatsoever on your day
it does not affect you it only affects
you in the sense that you may have
believed in that and it may have
affected your attitude otherwise or your
perception otherwise there is no bearing
on reality this has nothing to do with
that and the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam mentioned this when he was
described to have prohibited Tafoya
Wakana your G mu mu lfl o al Kelly metal
pie ever - yes Malka that he sallallahu
alayhi wasallam dispraised Atalaya
he dispraised that a person looked you
at these issues of bad luck or looking
at certain things to be ominous and he
on the other hand encouraged at fle
which is being optimistic and that is
that for example let's say somebody is
ill right they are in the hospital or
they are sick and they hear somebody
randomly say you know he is he's cured
was not to him but he heard this for an
individual to believe that this is
insha'Allah a glad tidings from a loss
of panama Tyla that i will be cured this
is something that is encouraged this is
something that is encouraged because it
entails good thinking good thoughts and
it's reinforces and bolsters our
been a loss of Hannah with Adam today in
shallow Thailand we are going to be
discussing its exact opposite the exact
opposite of a fail and that is those
things which are considered to be good
luck
more specifically charms good luck
charms whether those be bracelets or
watches or you know people talk about
they have a lucky hatch where they have
a lucky pair of shoes or they have lucky
pair of pants and anytime they go to do
something they go to do this thing with
this pair of pants or whatever it is
right or lucky times or days this is the
exact opposite of applicable at FIU is a
type of it is a type of minor
association of partners on to a loss of
panic with Adam and the other side which
is good luck charms or statements or
actions this is as well a type of
right it is a type of minor as the
scholars of Islam have mentioned and
categorized it and as the prophet
sallallaahu asylum before has
categorized it and that is that again
back to our confusion between
correlation and causation so if somebody
for example goes to work on a particular
day and they get us a promotion that
they've been waiting for right a lot of
people will be inclined to look at a
belt or some article of clothing they
were wearing or something that they had
done that day that they didn't usually
do that correlated with that happens
simultaneously on the same day as this
particular thing that they perceived to
be good happened and so this connection
is made where Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
has not made such a connection
you cannot disprove it and that is the
best indication that it is incorrect
scientifically speaking so there is no
way to prove that this has any bearing
or connection to this other thing that
happened the belt you are wearing and
the the promotion that you got or a
particular ritual that people do we have
this all over the place in America right
so for example in America on the 1st of
the year it is mentioned that on the 1st
of the year a person should eat cabbage
because if a cabbage they'll have a good
ear right this is a superstition this is
a type of or for example on Wall
Street the very very famous landmark
that is there on Wall Street in
Manhattan in New York the Raging Bull
and the stock market is right next to it
right Wall Street is right next to it or
it is on Wall Street and they the
stockbrokers every time they go into
their office is in the morning or after
lunch they will actually touch this bull
in a particular area on the bull that
gives them according to them good luck
for the day right so you've got the
entire bowl it's made out of bronze I
believe and it is black because it is
corroded with time but this one
particular place this one spot on the
bull is bright golden color and that is
because that's where it's constantly
being touched every day and so it
remains clean
right and polished this is a type of
ship this is what is known in Islam as a
table of look right which we will get
into so we have in in this issue of what
we would call in America or in the West
good luck
right we have this in a couple of forms
either it is something that we do right
or it is something that we or it is
something that we say or believe or look
for right so for example something that
we do I've mentioned with the with
the Raging Bull on Wall Street or for
example something that we say or belief
right we have certain certain
superstitions in America such as
crossing your fingers right or actors
when they go out to act or they go out
on stage it's common to be set break a
lake right break a leg means good luck
you know I wish good luck and it ties
back to you you know some superstition
in that or for example knock on wood
people knock on wood when they say you
know I haven't become sick yet knock on
wood right so to speak of this from a
particular angle we're going to speak
first about something that is very
common and that is what we refer to in
America as good luck charms or what we
refer to as talisman right so we have a
narration on the authority of a
Milanovic Elaine Otto the Eloheinu which
has been collected by even magic any man
I met didn't even have bad enough money
that the Prophet sallallahu aleyhi wa
salem once saw a man from the companions
will be a loved one home
had on his wrist had around his wrist
Halla cotton men so foreign
he had a thread tied around his wrist
and this thread was made of swivel which
the scholars of Islam discuss and differ
on what exactly that is whether it is a
wool or what kind of animal is taken
from but the point is that this Halawa
mince offal that he had on he believed
and the arabs at that time believed that
this thing would protect a person from
becoming ill from falling ill from
illness right and so the prophets all
alone I'll even sell him asked him when
he saw this around his wrist he said
Mahadi he what is this the man said
minute wayna it is something to protect
me from illness and the prophet
sallallaahu SLM said to him in zara for
analogy dukkha Elena he said rip it off
take it off because it will not increase
you in anything but illness meaning if
it it does not have any bearing on
reality however if it did the it would
it would have a negative effect rather
than a positive one and that is because
it causes the relationship between the
servants and Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to
become murky to become to become
severed to become diluted and so this
issue of wearing a talisman to ward off
evil things whatever it is or if a
person wears it in order to bring about
good things which is referred to as at
Tobruk these two things are considered
type of right and we have it's
equivalency in our culture if you go to
many drug stores I don't know if they
still do I'm sure they do
but you'll find what they call brass
bracelets right and people wear these
things on their wrists for arthritis
right and this is taken from the ancient
Romans who believed that this somehow
had an effect on a person's bones on a
person's joints there is no connection
whatsoever there is no connection
scientifically physically or religiously
that this is something that has any
bearing or effect on a person's joints
right this is the type of shift this
bracelet that people wear and and so
forth the prophet salaallah alayhi wa
salem had commanded that all of these
things be removed so he said so alone he
was selling for instance in the
narration of Aqaba hi banana mint i
lakota me matin fatima la who level
women a leper without and
Fairweather Allah who level well fear
aware it in mentality me matin suffered
a shock
he said sallallahu alayhi wasallam
whoever carries or uses a talisman what
we would call a good-luck charm this or
something that would ward off evil it's
right either to bring about good luck or
to ward off bad things he said soul
alone he was telling them that whoever
does this has fallen into a type of
we have this in different cultures what
has recently of late caught on in
America in fashion right a lot of
fashion a lot of things in fashion are
taken from ancient mythology is this
blue it's a blue circle or it may look
a teardrop right and it has a white
and a looks an eye and it's it's
blue right this is something that is
very common in Arab countries I know in
Palestine that is very prevalent people
hang it in their cars I've seen jewelry
made out of it women will wear this
jewelry on their earrings or necklaces
or men will as well right sometimes it's
in bracelets a maybe a bracelet
made out of fabric and it's got the
little eye in the middle and it's blue
and this is allegedly to ward off the
evil eye and it's all a caught on very
significantly here in America this as
well is a type of right this is a
type of shift
because the person is believing that
this thing somehow is a cause in warding
off something and allah subhanho wa
taala has not informed us of that and we
have no experiments we have no proven
way of knowing that it is nothing but
pure superstition right and Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala says he Debbie Aruna
II love bun he says that P these the
disbelievers or the people of the pagans
or the polytheists they only follow that
which is suspected something that they
are superstitious about it has no
bearing and reality there's no proof for
it and these are the types of things
that they believe in right so our minds
are to coincide with our beliefs our
brains and our minds the way we perceive
reality is that we look for real
provable cause for particular effects
however if we disregard our minds and
merely believe superstitions we become
gullible people and we become a people
who ascribe to Allah ascribe to the
reality of the unseen that which we have
no knowledge of and this exactly is how
the religion of the ancient pagan arabs
came about all of their superstitions
and their beliefs and the idols that
they worshiped they all have a history
but they are a history that have no
bearing on reality and so these things
are very very prohibited
in Islam and it may seem you know
not such a big deal it's kind of cute
cute it's it's pork it's not a big issue
but how many things in our daily lives
that we have been conditioned for seem
to be of little significance to us yet
with a loss of Hanna hua to Isla and
analy's estimate these things are very
serious a loss of Hannah with Tyler said
what I said wound up with a Henan what
were in the law he Eileen he said these
this thing that speaking about a
particular issue but in general you all
believe that this is of little
significance yet with a law and in a
laws estimate this is a very serious
affair in the hail mahadji in sahih
muslim abu Bashir little on Saudi but
I'll be alone who narrated that he was
accompanying the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wa seldom on a journey they were
traveling and the Messenger of Allah
Salih law my lady was seldom sent and if
you could imagine with me that when they
traveled there was a huge caravan of
travellers there's people on camels
people on mules people on donkeys people
walking right and so a caravan
especially if it's an army it could
span miles right as they follow each
other and so the Prophet sallallahu
aleyhi wa salem sent somebody to go and
and go to from the beginning of the
caravan all the way to the back of the
[Arabic recitation]
betty baron palladin min water in our
peloton in la cote odds
he said so alone I let you a seldom go
tell everybody in the entire caravan
that the messenger of allah has
commanded that there not remain a charm
on any camel or any charm hanging on any
animal except that it is cut off that it
is discarded and what is this what well
again we take the principle and we apply
it in our lives but it's it's parable or
its equal or equivalence in the time of
the prophets a little oh I'll you asylum
is they would have their bow that they
shoot arrows with it would be made out
of the tendons of camels or animals you
know they didn't have rubber obviously
in these types of synthetics that we use
to to cause that effect and so they
would take this and make it and it would
have that elastic effect and so when
this bow when this tendon became very
old and stretched out and doesn't have
the power that it used to have to shoot
the arrow desirably they would take it
off and put a new tendon on to make it
you know to rejuvenate his power now
this old tendon that they had used in
battle that they had used to hunt with
that they had used to shoot their prey
with that they had used to feed their
family that they had spent so much time
with this old tendon that they took off
which was the you know the rope or the
on the bow that would shoot the arrow
they would take this and hang it on
their camel hang it on their horse hang
it on their house or their tents
whatever it is
because they perceive this to be
something that would bring good luck
about or they would perceive this to be
something that would ward off bad luck
specifically the evil eye and so the
prophets all along i do a salem
commanded that none of these remain on
any of the animals that these be cut off
and discarded because they are of no
bearing in reality we believe we are we
are a people that are not superstitious
the muslims we are not superstitious
we are very logical we are grounded in
reality and we are guided by knowledge
not by superstitions and assumptions and
so we have similar things in america
that we use for example one that comes
to mind is that i that I had mentioned
or the dreamcatcher the Native Americans
would have this thing that and it has
feathers hanging off of it and it's
called a dreamcatcher everybody probably
knows what I'm speaking about and this
would either ward off evil or it would
bring about good right and this is from
Native American Indians in America
that's basically they were pantheists
they believed in nature they worshipped
nature very similar in theory to
Hinduism however it is different in its
expression obviously and so this is
something that they would use for good
luck work or whatever it is and so this
is a type of that people have
people even use this to
you know they may even tattoo its on
their bodies
another one that is very popular is
amongst Christians is the cross and we
see in movies depictions that the cross
Ward's off evil and person believes in
it it will you know burn a vampire and
all of this silliness this as well
is a type of to ward off these evil
spirits allegedly a person would use a
cross also garlic I know that sounds
silly but I've actually gone to people
on their deathbed where they have garlic
around them we asked why why do you have
this well this is so no no and they're
Muslim right is this so no evil spirits
come around the person who is dying in
his last final moments this is all a
type of likewise I lived in the
Caribbean for a very long time they had
certain certain spirits that they
believed people would turn usually old
ladies would turn into this ball of fire
that would go around at night and suck
people's blood and the way to ward this
office to put a line of salts on the
entrances of the house right none of
these things have any bearing in reality
no no no connection to reality
whatsoever Allah subhana WA Ta'ala gave
us in these things stead he gave us
ayatul kursi he gave us surat al fatiha
he gave us surat al-baqara right in
which he said sallallahu aleyhi wa salem
in the Surat al-baqarah after her Baraka
water que ha ha surah Valerius tiro
Helmuth allah and its
he said so Aloha Lewis elements are he a
Muslim that learning Surat al-baqarah is
of great consequence and of great
blessing and not learning Surat
al-baqarah is a great loss and magicians
and these types of individuals magicians
and witches and so forth they can never
overpower or they have no ability to
bear Surat al-baqarah and so we have
things that are really grounded in
reality which are the words of Allah
subhana wa tada that have a bearing on
the spiritual world around us in Islam
we are taught that there are spirits
there are the jinn and people would
experience these jinn throughout time
they would come in contact with them and
these things would scare them and so
they would try to come up with a way to
settle their minds and quell their fears
so they would either try to reach out to
these spirits and worship them with some
type of worship right some kind of
offering we have in Arab culture
today amongst Muslims that when you get
a new house that you bring goat or a
sheep some kind of animal and you
slaughter it at the door of the house
and this is an offering to any jinn that
happened to be in the house that they
you know this is an offering to them or
it is for a loss of kind of a tattoo
they say either way this is
impermissible and this is either a type
of major or minor shift or innovation
this is not something that is part of
our religion right slaughtering for
other than Allah Subhanahu
Tyla is a type of major ship that
invalidates a person's islam and so the
prophet sallallahu aleyhi wa salem says
as well in the narration of hippodamus
ode collected by imam ahmed and up with
that would to seduce Danny
he said I heard the messenger of allah
sallallahu alayhi wasallam sa in naka
what Tamar EEMA with T Willetta Sher
Khan he says in rokka rokka this is he
says that a worker and tama m and Thiele
these three things are type of ship
now we'll explain what these are at
tomaten we spoke about which are
talismans things that we believe that if
you wear it or Don it or if you put it
on your house or put it in your car or
whatever it is that it is somehow going
to ward off evil in some places even in
Palestine where I'm from people will
when they are making their house they're
designing their house they will put
money in the walls when they're building
the walls when they're constructing the
walls they believe that this will you
know ward off any evil spirits that if
you put money in the walls or they will
put particular symbols or papers in the
walls or at the doorway for instance as
well we have certain things that people
do that they believe is you know like
for example very common in in
Palestinian culture that when you go to
get married and you're going to do the
actual marriage contract that everybody
needs to lay his hands out flat you to
make sure there's nothing in your hands
your fingers aren't crossed
because if you hold your hands this
or this or put them in your pockets
somehow this will cause the marriage to
get off on the wrong foot right this is
well is a very serious type of
superstition that falls more into a to
fail but tamam is what we mentioned is
when a person uses a thing that they
make a string symbol whatever it is to
ward off evil of roca is the same idea
but it is something that you say it is
verbal right we have Autopia in Islam
which is a collection of dua and
recitation of the Quran and praise of
allah subhana wa ta'ala this is the
Rokia that allah subhana wa tada has
given us for those who are ill those who
are ailing etc but there are other types
of alcohol which come from soothsayers
or magicians or superstitions or
paganism that people say in order to try
to cure somebody or something or try to
bring about good luck we mentioned some
examples of this one of them is as we
mentioned for a person to say knock on
wood and knock on wood or to actually
find something wooden to knock one right
these are as well a type of ship this is
a type of exaltation of other than a
loss of Hannah with data in a way that
other than Allah should not be exalted
it is likewise making a connection of
causation between two things that Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala has not informed us of
and we have not been able to prove in
our physical reality
right
[Silence]
and there are a number of things that
people do obviously that people say and
the general rule is that something being
a cause for something else will only be
proven an Islamic law based on one of
two ways number one is that a loss of
Hanna who is added informs us of it
through the Quran through the Sunna of
the prophets of Allah Almighty was said
right so he has informed us that
reciting ate a will be of great
consequence and will protect a person as
they sleep for instance this is one way
that we make a connection of cause the
second is that we have a trial and error
we go through this thing where for
example we find out for example we find
a particular herb or a particular thing
that we take for this particular illness
and through experimentation we found
that it has this real effect right that
it has this real effect on this illness
that's how we that's how we learn about
medicine that's how we learn about the
world around us and if we can't make
that connection and if that connection
is really provable and if it is
disprovable as well
then and if this can continue then we
understand that this is a way to prove
causation my microphone was acting up
there and it was being it was very very
distracting now the third thing that the
province alone you're seldom mentioned
is a tea without tea Willa is something
that the Arabs and the time of the
prophet sallallaahu seldom would use
till they believed that a woman could
you make this thing whatever it's made
out of whether it's braided or designed
and fashioned in some way and this thing
would make a husband love his wife or
cause there to be a strong bond between
the two right this is a type of shift as
well and there's a lot of superstitions
around things that we can't understand
or things that we view to be very
serious this is where superstitions
usually come from right so people are
they are usually do not understand death
and so there's a lot of superstitions
with regards to death and those things
which are been considered to be a big
deal such as marriage this is also
another thing where you'll find it just
absolutely enveloped in superstition
right because people get married
especially you know long ago when
marriage was a lot more sacred people
viewed it to be very sacred which it is
in the Quran that you're getting married
to this person this is your chance this
is your only chance you know and so they
would make all kinds of superstitions to
make sure that it goes right
get off on the right foot so in America
we have things the groom can't see
the bride before the marriage I mean
they've been living together in America
they've living together they have kids
they've been living together for 15
years but on that particular day the
groom cannot see the bride before
getting married because that will be bad
luck right this is of course nonsense
however these are things that many
Muslims unfortunately have learned
observed from others and they have
adopted these things a very dangerous
thing that the prophet sallal oma he was
selling has mentioned a very dangerous
terrible repercussion of the
superstitions is the statement of the
Prophet sallallahu aleyhi wa salem which
was collected by ahmed annette timothy
mandala Pasha and Whoopie day later
whoever believes in a talisman will be
placed at a disposal of that talisman
right whoever believes in a talisman or
a good luck charm or something that will
ward off evil whoever believes in this
thing
a loss of kind of what the eye that will
make this thing this string this symbol
this whatever it is make this thing a
disposer of that person's affair what
does that mean that means that a loss of
panaqua ta-da'-da will make this
particular thing the disposer of the
that person's affairs in this life and
that thing that which he believed in
right and this goes back to a principle
in in the Quran as to how allah subhana
wa tada deals with his creation in which
he says will mania shelter us
embodiment opinion a level without way
to verify our civilian meaning Yee meta
Weyland he said Japan with Islands were
often lessor and whoever disobeys
disregards contends with the messenger
after truth has been made clear to him
and follows a path other than the path
and the way of the believers we will
commit him to that path that he has
chosen well ehi motto Allah we will
commit him to that path and so when a
person believes in something and they
have no proof no evidence but they
believe in it simply because it has been
whispered to them they have been excited
by a ship on or culture or whatever it
is to believe in this particular thing
they will find whatever it is they look
for and why is that why do they find
whatever it is they look for because
they have chosen that path and a loss of
Pi no it's a data convince them to that
path we ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to
protect us from our own ignorance let he
forgive us our sins and that he teach us
that which has beneficial to us and that
he benefit us from that which he teaches
[Arabic recitation]
ala nabina muhammad whether he was happy
he attained